哈囉大家好 歡迎
來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天邀請的大來賓是我的
好朋友雪力老師
耶 大家好我又來了
開心開心開心
我剛剛有故意耶
的時候離遠一點
因為我每次耶
的時候都會太開心
因為很多人都說很喜歡看雪力
老師跟我就是對談
所以我們今天又
邀請了雪力老師
謝謝謝謝
而且我們平常其實
真的是有在聊天的
沒錯真的聊得很開心
然後我覺得從雪力老師身上
常常學到很多東西
有互相啦～
從你身上，我也覺得每次跟你
聊好像就自己有被諮商過
我也是覺得很開心
那我下次就是我們
就開始放個計時器
設個時間
但其實這一次就是找雪力老師來
還有一個很大的原因
那就是雪力老師
終於又開新課了耶
雪力老師要不要
講一下你新課的名字？
我這一次開的課是
「人生系統設計課」
為什麼會開這堂課呢
一個很大的原因是
我覺得大部分的人認識我都
還是透過MBTI
一直到現在都
還是有類似的問題
譬如說我的
MBTI會不會改啊
或者是我想知道人家的
MBTI是什麼
我知道怎麼跟他相處～
所以我覺得推廣了這麼久
我發現大家還是卡
在人本身的身上
可是我想要推的系統課
更多是運用組織心理學
就是我本來的背景
來講說行為是
來自於人與環境的互動
我們不是活在真空包裝裡面
所以我不能說
慕茲你這個INTP
你走到哪裡你的
行為都會一模一樣
因為你在跟很安全的人聊天
跟你覺得很緊張
或者是有對你有
威脅的人聊天的時候
你的行為一定是不一樣的
所以我不能看著你的行為說
欸 你今天這樣子
很不INTP喔
所以我希望大家
可以透過系統學
就是組織心理學來看到說
了解個人是一個很重要的部分
因為你有些自我覺察
你看到自己的強項跟陰影
但是你一定要理解說
你跟其他的人互動
我們每個人都有自己的投射
大家投來投去亂七八糟的
你要看得懂這個局
這樣子你才不會在那邊過度的
努力在自己的身上
或者是怪罪別人
因為我覺得很多人
壓力下就會覺得說
你之前出的內耗課
我覺得就是探討這個就是
我可以怎麼樣再改變
那有些人就是我都沒問題
都是我老公我小孩
我老闆好了
我的人生就完美了
就是都沒有看到就是
我們人跟外在的互動
會造成我們的行為
會形成一些關係的動力
所以這次我比較專注在講
這個大方向的系統上面
我覺得這個超棒的耶
因為其實在我們學的就是
關於心理諮商、心理學
其實大部分比較後現代的理論
很強調系統的影響
那所謂系統的影響
大家不要覺得說
聽起來怎麼這麼懸
系統的影響其實伴侶也是系統
然後家庭也是系統
那你像剛剛雪力說的
一般我們企業在
說的組織心理學
也是系統
一個國家也是系統
甚至一個世界也是系統
所以系統基本來說就是
我們在這個環境裡面每一個人
他會在這個環境
裡面的關係動力
會影響我們的行為
所以雪力剛剛在
講到就是INTP
我覺得很有趣
因為我們剛剛中間
就在聊一個東西
我就直接在這邊分享
因為大家都會對
INTP有一些想像
可是其實我在
平常工作上的表現
沒有這麼INTP
甚至有很多人覺得我是E人
或者像是我學心理諮商
我給的很多回應
很多人會覺得我很F嘛
你是可以接到別人的情緒的
就是我們看到的是這樣
但是我剛剛就跟雪力聊到
就是剛好有一次
我有訪問丁寧老師
然後跟他聊
他就聊到說
他在有一次跟他
先生吵架的時候
就很氣很氣
他就跑進去浴室
把浴缸給打破了
然後我那個時候我都不曉得
就是我們後製有沒有
大家也很好心幫
我把那一句剪掉
我不知道那句有沒有被留下來
因為我記得我
聽到這句話的時候
我的大腦在思考
我的下一句話就立刻問
那個浴缸是什麼材質的
那他說什麼
然後他就他也愣了一下
他心裡想說怎麼會問這個？
他就說是塑膠還是玻璃纖維
我記得他好像是就是回答一個
他也不是很清楚之類的
但是他其實露出
的確有一點點困惑
就想說怎麼會問這個問題
然後我那時候一問出這句
我就知道糟糕我怎麼會問這個
我應該要先
就是回一個同理的句子
「你一定很生氣」
或是這樣我們才可以把話題
就是引導到就是談他的內心
那個時候怎麼會這樣
可是我自己就很清楚
這個是我很直覺性第一個反應
就是跟之前有那個韓國廣告
就是對方說我心情很差
所以我去麵包店買了一個麵包
然後對方就說那
你買了什麼麵包
然後他就很生氣
那真的是我們就是一般
直覺性思考會問
因為我會問的就會是
那你去哪一間麵包店
因為我就會想說
那家麵包店這麼好吃
你心情不好都會去那家麵包店
那我下次也要去那個麵包店
就我的思考就會是這樣
可是在我平常有訓練的表現
或是我比如說
我知道這個環境對我的期待
我現在這個身份要做什麼事情
我表現的不一定會是很T的
因為這個部分是不是
這個表現就很T
所以其實你看那個訪談
其實是相對安全的
或者是互相尊重的
所以對方會可能會
認了一下
可是他還是回應了
然後可能不會想太多
可是我們可以想一下
假使我們兩個關係
現在是非常緊張的
那你講這個話我就覺得
你是
伴侶就會很生氣
比如說我們已經
結婚了十幾年了
然後我已經在表達
我的憤怒的時候
INTP來說
那你砸的是什麼東西
就是這是重點嘛對不對
所以我覺得很多時候
我們不能光看
一個行為去批判他
而是說這個行為
就是我們兩個的
關係是有多深了
然後我們兩個的權力
誰的權力比較大
因為今天如果你是我老闆
你這樣講
我一定是完全接受
是是是
哈哈哈哈對
但是如果你是我下屬的話
我可能有不同的反應
所以其實看一個系統就是說
我們同樣的一句話
我們要看是什麼
角色在講對不對
這個人有多少權限
我們兩個有什麼樣子的交情
那我就跟你講
因為我老公也是INTP
我們兩個狀況好的時候啊
就是夫妻感情非常好的時候
他有時候講這些話
我就覺得他好可愛
但是大部分的時間
哈哈哈哈
像以前就是小孩子的事情
我要處理嘛
我們也是分工分好了
可是你知道處理完以後
他就會問說
那你為什麼選這個
你知道當我工作
壓力已經很大了
就是我們兩個都上班
那我要負責小孩子的事情
當我壓力很大的時候
我的反應是
你不做你還要質疑我
就是我的假設是當別人問問題
這是我的原廠設定
可是我就要跳出來說
我認識他這麼久
他純粹真的就是想知道
但是我壓力大的時候
我的反應是不一樣
因為我覺得這個時候
我們關係的安全感
我自己的壓力荷爾蒙
是暴增的時候
我看不到這一面
我就會說
你不要問了
如果你要問你就自己去做
但是我的狀態好的時候
我就知道他
為什麼要問這件事情
所以我覺得
INTP尤其在組織裡面
因為你們會問一些比較跳脫
大家思維的問題
所以INTP在組織裡面
扮演的角色就非常明顯
就是你在這個團隊裡面
是不是有權力的
在組織圖裡面
你是在多上面
你是 report 給誰的
會非常的影響INTP
在這個組織活得好不好
而且好不好用
但是其他的類型
也許就是比較容易
觀察別人情緒的
相對的影響
也許少一點點
那更多可能是內耗
但是我覺得INTP有的時候
會在組織裡面
被針對的原因是這樣
因為問了重要的問題
問了「大哉問」
跟別人回答不出來
然後大部分的人會期待
不管是T人還是F人
都期待被看見跟被尊重
不是解決問題先
我覺得這件事情滿有趣的
這是我當時覺得MBTI
是對我幫助很大的東西
就是我倒沒有覺得說
我一定要是INTP
可是我覺得包含那時候發現
原來我是比較偏i人
不是Ｅ人
然後我是T人
因為我後來就發現
我在工作的時候非常明顯
就是我會意識到
在遇到一些狀況
比如說我的合作
夥伴挫折的時候
但是是因為我們遇到一些問題
挫折的時候
即使我是心理師
我的第一個反應
絕對不是安慰他心情
我第一個反應絕對是
我們現在問題在哪裡
我們把處理完
處理完你心情就好了
我的思考我以前
沒有意識到這件事
但是我非常非常強烈的感受到
我遇到越大
大家越沮喪、越挫折、越難的時候
我就是第一個跳出來說
好我們現在狀況是怎麼樣
怎麼樣怎麼樣
我們現在有什麼問題
這樣這樣這樣
那我們第一件事情做什麼
第二件事情做什麼
第三件事情做什麼
所以以危機處理來說
我是一個很適合
被推出來的對象
可是在有些時候人際關係上
感覺有點不近人情
對 所以我覺得
MBTI那時候
帶給我的禮物也是說
你要看到每一個類型的人
他真的真的就是上天給的禮物
因為你在這樣的狀況下
你可能就需要ISTP
INTP的人
他就是自帶包廂的
可以在這個危機的時候
跟外界的這個情緒切斷
來好好想事情
所以為什麼我一直覺得
James Bond就是
007他是ISTP
就是他也沒有一個大的計畫
反正他是邊摸邊走
然後他在危機的時候
他可以很冷靜
所以不敬人情
你看跟誰比
但是事實上是在這個時候
我們就非常需要這樣子的人
可是在這樣子的人
你看到一個團體裡面
就會有一種共識
就是人與人之間
會組織在
在一起就會變成一個文化
所以我去一個都是
ISTP的公司好了
然後如果我是一個
所謂情商很高的人
然後很能夠看人家的情緒
來調整我自己行為
我如果去一間
公司都是ISTP
最累的人是我
那你去一間大家都
每天相親相愛
然後只要問這種尖銳問題
就會被翻白眼的公司
ISTP就會很痛苦
所以我覺得沒有什麼
不對的類型或不好的類型
而是說我有沒有看到說
我有沒有在一個
支持我的系統裡面
不是我是ISTP
所以我人生會碰到很多困境
很多人說我是INFJ
我是INFP
所以我的人生特別困難
我不敢否認這件事情
因為我們的社會上面的氛圍
比較是偏EJ的
那可是就是你還是可以找到
支持你的團體對不對
就是你要瞭解
我可以從系統裡面
我要找什麼樣的系統
或者是我可以用什麼工具
來調整我的系統
其實是可以做到的
所以其實選擇
你在說的這個東西
很重要就是你之前
在開MBTI課
是幫助我們瞭解我們的天賦
跟潛能
跟什麼事情我們
做起來比較舒服
我就說我那時候因為認識
你才真的好好的知道
MBTI這個東西
我覺得光知道我是
I人的這件事情
給我的力量就好大
就是大家可能很難理解
我以前一直覺得去做E的事情
是非常正常的
然後我對於自己有時候要做
很拋頭露面的事情我會很累
我其實是會有點責備自己的
所以當我發現我是哀人
然後我發現原來我需要這麼多
跟自己相處的時間之後
我就發現這件事情對我真的是
一個很大的理解跟解放
所以在前面MBTI
我們開的課是用
讓大家更理解自己
但是後來大家在理解自己
有時候會過度鑽研
就是說那我就是因為我就是
比如說我就是IMTP
所以我應該連做諮商的時候
我都很問題導向
沒有我做諮商的時候
一點都不問題導向
那我為什麼會有這樣的變化
難道就是因為我有時候會變嗎
我就是有時候是T
有時候是F人
我覺得是不是為了
要解決這樣的狀況
所以這一次的系統課
其實是幫助我們
就理解自己的能力之後
我知道這個事
我也要知道這個
世界發生什麼事
我才知道我被安放在什麼時候
對我比較舒服
什麼時候可能我會不夠
然後我就要去發展某些能力
還有我應該要選擇什麼樣的路
好比我們現在在用MBTI
瞭解我們自己
我們把自己比喻成車好了
我怎麼分析我就是法拉利
可是我實際看到的就是
我原地不動我跑不快
法拉利不是都跑很快嗎
那為什麼
我怎麼樣看盤點我的資源
我就是跑不快
那你有沒有看到你
現在開在泥漿裡面
相對的這時候那個
JEEP就會跑很快
對不對
就是說你光分析
你是什麼樣子的車
這是第一步而已
那你要看外面是什麼樣子的路
對不對
你如果一直開錯路
這不適合你的路
或者這個系統根本
沒有支持你的話
那你就看到你的行為
我覺得這時候就
可能會造成內耗說
奇怪我覺得我的能力在這裡
可是我為什麼在這裡
為什麼
我可以怎麼樣做更好
可是你法拉利卡在泥漿裡面
不是靠你的努力就可以更好的
就是你需要被拖住
你需要有些工具把你撈出來
那我覺得很多人
沒有看到這一點
只覺得我靠我的蠻力
我就是用力在加油
我加油加油
所以我覺得我們很喜歡說加油
因為有的時候
不是加油是停下來
看到說我卡在哪裡
那這就是我說的系統
我覺得這個系統很重要
剛剛雪姬這樣說
因為有時候我們努力錯方向
可能是我們其實
在做跟這個系統
完全相反
適合的事情
這讓我想到一個有點題外話
有點好笑
因為我身邊朋友大部分都是J人
然後他們在跟我聊
一些事情的時候
就突然很感慨
因為我們諮商所
工作的行政人員
也都是賊人
然後他就說
為什麼好像台灣賊人比較多
Ｐ人比較少
就是他就覺得
因為身邊大部分都是Ｊ人
我說不是
我說你錯了
那是跟我們的工作環境有關
我說以我們的行政人員
你想想看
我們諮商所有Ｐ人
就是我跟另外一個人
我說你會想要給
我們兩個做行政嗎
你會覺得找我們
兩個進來做這件事情
可以嗎
我們P人沒辦法做這個事情
可能就是也許有些策略
或是有一些新的創意
開什麼新的課
這種我們做得到
但是要做這種就是很
就是很瑣碎很細的事情
我說所以不是因為沒有P人
是因為你們不要P人
或者是P人
他自己不想要來做這份工作
行政相關
對
我覺得另外一個系統
可以幫你的就是
好我今天我已經是P人了
比如說很多內向傾向人做
YouTuber
對不對
或做主持人
創作者
OK
我愛創作
但不代表
我可以馬上反應的過來
或者是我大腦
我有時候需要沉思一點
那我用系統來協助我
比如說我有大螢幕
在上面可以有提卡的提卡機
對不對
這就是系統
我可以設計我的環境
讓它來彌補
或者是支持我可能的盲點
或者是我不擅長的事情
那我的工作夥伴
也都是批傾向的
真的喔
對
所以我覺得他們很可憐
這真的是互補耶
因為我的都好像比較J
但是因為我是J人
我就會說
然後這個呢
所以我覺得他們現在都很厲害
他們自己就用一套系統
就是知道我要問什麼問題
它反正就是所有東西都填進去
那如果是批就是
我想到什麼
我可能我的自然模式
不是說這麼一步一步的來
可是因為我們要在這個團隊
一起合作
那我可不可以設計一個
什麼樣子的東西工具
來支持我
所以我工作的時候
我不會這麼困擾
我就直接把東西填進去
那所有
那就剛好是
Jerron要看的東西了
所以我可以
我可以這麼理解嗎
所以雪力這一次開的這個課
它有點像是我們就是
從原本自我出發
到看懂系統
就是我們現在的
環境發生什麼事
到思考為了這個環境
或是也許我當然可以選擇
其他環境
我可以去設計我的環境
我怎麼讓環境變成適合我
所以我需要用一些工具
讓自己可以
不管是fit這個環境也好
或是去調整這個環境也好
其實這門課就是在做這樣的
其實真的是這樣
從那天再跟那個
學老師在談八字
他就講說七煞的人
有什麼樣的特質
那我就提了一些說
那你覺得他會有什麼樣的狀況
我們就看有什麼工具
可以來協助他
那比如說我在組織裡面
做高階主管教練
有的時候就會發現
兩個部門主管他就是卡住
那其實有些工具
你就可以把你的責任
就是切乾淨對不對
其實很多時候
我們就是沒講清楚
世代也是一樣
為什麼這個世代的人這麼難管
就是你跳出來看
不要光看那些世代的特質
你要跳出來看
更大的環境對他們有什麼影響
我們
你比我年輕了
但是我們GenX
或者是更老的
其實我們那時候工作
是真的是賣命
因為我們賣命工作
10年 20年
是可以買得起房子的對不對
有的時候10年就可以買得起
再年輕一點
社會大環境在改變的時候
你的生存法則一定會調整
但是在職場上面
我們很多時候就是
沒有把規範講清楚
抽話沒有講出來
或者是覺得你應該要懂
這個是職場的道德
可是你不知道道德兩個字
會隨著文化
會隨著時間調整跟改變
所以我每次進去組織講說
我們世代的溝通
其實很多時候是
我們太專注在人的身上了
你沒有跳出來看到說
這個大環境是怎麼
對待這個世代的
當初是怎麼對待我們的
所以他們的生存法則
跟我們的生存法則
跟我們看工作的重要性
是不太一樣的
那是正常的
那我覺得
就像你說的
MVT也是這樣
你一旦看到了
其實就釋懷了一大半
也不是說它真的改變你的人生
好像就是我說之前說更年期
我還是有可能肩膀痛什麼
可是我一旦知道
我不用到處去看醫生
原來原因是這樣子
其實那個心就解放了一大半
對 因為好像那個情緒
跟那個未知的東西
就有地方可以安放
所以因為組織心理學
其實之前我也很有興趣
因為它跟系統很有關係
可是它在講的
其實更是企業中工作的動力
因為我們一般在講
像家庭的
或是在講伴侶的
其實我之前有時候在別的課
也有提到常常像家族理論
它有一個概念
它會說焦慮這件事情
它的單位是家庭
所以它不是個人
所以很多人以為
是我自己的焦慮
但其實這個焦慮
是來自於這一個
家庭的互相傳遞
所以常常會出現一個狀態
如果是我們在講家庭系統理論
就會出現一個狀態
比如說這個父母
標記了一個孩子
這個孩子有問題
他一天到晚出問題
他生病
或是他一天到晚在學校找麻煩
然後父母總是要帶著他
不管是去看醫生也好
或者是要帶著他去找心理師
或是去找一些治療師
然後或是去看醫生
或是找老師等等
然後大家都一直覺得
是這個孩子有問題
但是在我們的系統理論裡面
就會有一個說這個孩子
他有可能是
是替罪羔羊
或者是說他在手足裡面
他就是...
例如說大家手足
他就是那個最容易會被家裡
覺得是有問題
或是被當替罪羊的那個人
這個孩子在做這件事情
很有可能其實是為了
例如說父母其實一直在吵架
父母的關係不好
所以父母關係最好的時候
就是他們一起帶著孩子
到處求醫
或者是去找別人
就是解決孩子的問題的時候
所以這個孩子就是
下意識的一直就是出問題
對對對
然後這個其實也是一個
焦慮情緒的傳遞
然後這個東西當然
我現在講的很簡單
大家可能覺得很玄
很像玄學
不是就是很多像就是一些
就是家族理論在講
一些案例的時候
其實常常出現這樣子的狀況
如果大家有興趣的話
可以去找就是
家庭治療學者 Minuchin（薩爾瓦多·米紐欽）
的一些書籍
可是我
因為我有注意到
雪力這一次在開就是
這個系統課的時候
也特別講到系統的代罪羔羊
所以我很好奇
我剛剛講的這個東西
和雪力你課程裡面在解釋了
這個東西是不是
非常像而且絕對可以延伸
因為其實我們在看
家庭系統的時候
我不是之前每次都說
欸 慕茲你推薦我諮詢
是因為我朋友都在問
可是他們每次問的時候
都是來問說
我覺得我小孩有問題
可是我每次都跟他講說
我會建議你們一起諮詢
因為我自己小孩在
自閉症光譜上的時候
我去研究所回來
我就第一個領悟說
我家不是有一個
自閉症光譜的孩子
我們是一個自閉症
光譜上面的家庭
這個是我們的
我們講集體共業好像
有一點太over
但是是一個我們團隊裡面
共創出來的一個動力
就是用系統的眼光去看
這是我們大家一起要
去面對的一個影響
沒錯沒錯
就是所以我也跟我
其他兩個小孩講說
你一定要知道我們
這是我們互動出來的結果
也許我們不是很清楚
怎麼互動出來的結果
但事實上是這樣子
而且他的狀況會影響我們
每一個人的行為
所以我們一定要把自己
搶成這樣子的單位
所以我覺得在亞洲社會相對的
比較能夠理解
因為我們比較不是個人主義
但我覺得在西方社會
但我們慢慢的也
走向個人主義了
所以就比較難看到
我們跟系統的連結
那剛剛講的是家庭
所以在一個不健康的家庭裡面
尤其是酗酒
最多研究對不對
你裡面一定是有
一個是酗酒的人
然後一個是 enabler（助長者/共依附角色）
就是支持他繼續
繼續上癮的人
一個英雄
一個替罪羊
一個黑羊
一定是有這樣子的劇本
你在組織裡面同樣的
當一個組織在集體焦慮的時候
他也是會碰到一些狀況
那譬如說
如果我們整個組織是
互相相愛的
但是我們的心理
安全感還不夠的時候
就有可能會出現
一個叫做 Abilene paradox
就是愛比零掉鬼
那他其實講的故事很妙
就是一個家庭他住在德州
夏天非常的熱
然後爸爸就說
我們要不要開
我們的沒有冷氣的車
一起去Abelin吃飯
然後他老婆就
好啊好啊
女兒就說爸媽也想去
好啊很棒一起去
女婿當然沒話說
那大家都想去一起去
然後開了兩小時來回
然後吃了一頓很難吃的飯
然後大家回家爸爸就說
我不是為了你們
我根本不想開車去
其他人就說
那我們才不想去了對不對
所以在組織裡面
你會看到這樣子的互動
這就跟人格類型沒有關係了
因為他是一個團體互動
你說那個女婿
大部分的人就會跟著走
就是我怎麼能在一個文化裡面
自己跳出來說
不好意思老闆
我覺得這樣不OK
全公司都覺得OK
我自己覺得不OK
所以你會看到就是說
在團體也在焦慮的時候
我們有可能也會希望
有投射一個人
就是都是會計
大家就投射在會計太機車
我們換掉會計
大家就和諧了
然後你去組織就會看到
奇怪 會計這個位置
一直做不久
會有某些人的位置
會一直都是超高的流動率
流動率超高的
那就是可能大家把所有的
不滿投射在這個工作上面
那這是在組織裡面
很明顯會看到的
好有道理
因為快計它最容易不進人情
因為它規則很清楚
然後它又講到錢的東西
錢最容易引發我們的安全感
跟焦慮
嚴格來說其實是這樣
然後又會影響我們
覺得我們有沒有獲得資源
有沒有被照顧
為什麼它申請錢很容易
我申請錢很難
然後為什麼我不爽
就會這樣
然後另外一個部分是
如果今天我還想做這個工作
我理論上就不能太氣老闆
所以我能氣誰
大部分的時候
生氣的對象都是會計
所以我覺得這好
有道理非常好玩
但我要講一個
你要看公司它的診斷就是
譬如說
每個人生病的地方不一樣
有的人是腸胃生病
會計
會計是一種
你就知道它有其中一種狀態
有的地方是業務
有的地方是研發
有的地方是產品
有的地方是QA
有的地方是老闆
老闆其實通常
會大家一起共同討厭老闆
不是一件壞事情
因為大家會團結
所以有些老闆會使這一招
但是不是每個老闆都受得了
但是另外一個在全世界看得到
找到共同敵人
其他公司
就其他部門
我要讓我們團結在一起的時候
那其實還有很多團體動能
就是第二次世界大戰的時候
他們也發現很多受傷的士兵
就是明明都是非常聰明的人
但是當你在非常無助
無奈的時候
會忽然失去所有的方向
然後就等待救世主的出現
也許我們公司被
買掉下一個老闆
就會拯救所有的一切
就是完全失去自己的功能了
這些都是人與人之間
互動出來的這種動力
這個好有趣
因為如果這個
把它放到我所學
的家族理論裡面
它有很多類似
像比如說像剛剛說的就是
如果是一個有酗酒的家庭
它一定是有一個喪失功能的人
跟有功能的人
有功能的人就會讓失功能的人
越來越喪失功能
所以這它就是一個
慈母多拜兒的概念
應該來講說工作上也會這樣嘛
就是例如說一個非常有力的
能力很好的主管
它下面常常在抱怨它的
誰誰誰做事不夠
不夠給力、沒辦法
它常常請假誰怎樣
就是它會發現
它下面常常在處理這個問題
對很常發生
然後就是很有力的下屬
就會說我的主管很沒有用
可是很好玩的地方就是
如果這個主管太有用的話
這個下屬的能力就
沒有辦法表現了
然後這個主管如果就是
比較沒有用的時候
這個可能下屬做了很多
但是它有機會被看見
但是它又會覺得
我都在幫你收拾或是
所以這個東西也是
像剛剛雪力說的
是一個系統的一個
動力的一個展現
就是如果你是老闆的時候
你就要看
你就開始說我們要把權限
我們可以用bar這個工具
我們來切分
大家的工作範圍是什麼
對不對
因為有的時候
我看我的老闆這麼弱
我想要幫忙
我幫到後來
可能他反而不敢指我說我越權
是對不對
所以我在幫忙之前
我應該要先確認
我的權限在哪裡
不是我不出手
可是我的權限在哪裡
就是讓你有一個工具就是說
那我
我其實現在真的太困擾
我也不知道我要不要幫我老闆
還是我就這樣子放任
那你就照著工具去
double check
你只要有一個工具去
你最起碼90%不會錯
好讚哦有那個工具
所以嚴格來說
就是這就是我們
以前常常看的那種
就是歷史劇
不管是哪一國的
歷史劇都會出現
就是什麼將軍啊
就是不管是西方跟
東方都有什麼將軍
在外面打仗啊
然後太厲害啊
然後後來就是帝王就一直覺得
越來越怎麼樣
然後就要把他那個
可是那個感覺就很像是
因為這個將軍
他可能擁有太多的能力
擁有太多的力量
甚至他處理太多的問題
他覺得有些事情
我問你你不一定有能力解決
所以我不如自己處理
而這個部分
他可能覺得他是
在幫這個帝王忙
但是對這個領導者來說
他會感覺到威脅
就是我好像越來越沒有力量
全部的事情都被你拿走了
所以你以為你在幫忙
我以為我們人跟人之間有感情
我以為我跟你有感情
所以我在幫忙你
而且很多有能力的人
都有親職化
就是我要幫那個大人做事情
可是這個大人不一定喜歡
被做這些事
特別在企業裡面
因為他會有權力的問題
我覺得我自己
之前就是親身體驗
因為我覺得同樣的劇本
一直在我人生發生
就是我覺得我做了
為別人做了很多
沒有被感激
所以在我的劇本裡
我有一點可憐
就是我是那種可憐的長女
可憐就是有能力的長女
這樣子聽起來比較讚
然後做了很多事情
大家都沒有看到
我就自己默默做
而且我是能者多勞
就是多多少少
你在抱怨的背後
有一點點驕傲對不對
因為我的能力
可是我一直到很後來才發現說
人家不感激你是因為第一個
沒有人叫你做啊
然後你做了以後
你是怎麼樣
你就是說
「對啊，你看我多厲害」
那我在講我多厲害的時候
相對的要講的是什麼
你多糟嘛
你沒有能力
所以我做嘛
所以我不知不覺的也把
你沒有能力這個
形象套在你身上
也許我不是故意的
可是這是你的感受
那也許你有一些想法
你只是時間還沒到還沒有做
就是我越線了
我越權了
那我們的這個界線跟空間
一開始就沒有
一個工具提醒我說
欸 我去確認一下
就是有那個職權的確認
我也沒有確認我的職權
我應不應該跳進去
你的人生為你的人生負責
你當然如果要求就是
你請求幫助
那是另外一回事
因為我覺得我們人
在請求幫助的時候
我們內在是有一把尺
就是說 OK
這次你幫我
那我知道我欠你
對不對
那這是我要的
可是當別人不要的時候
喂人家吃飽飽
你一直叫人家吃
把它塞進去
然後說你看我都做給你吃的
你還不感激我
人家不是也很痛苦
對
然後所以我其實
那個時候發現
我的人生劇本有一直在重演
然後我就常常在
就像之前我就說
我老公我就會抱怨說
你看什麼事情都是我做
那你還要東問西問
對不對
然後你的壓力
指數提高的時候啊
其實發現兩件事情
一個就是
你的
記憶力會下降
你就忘記愛的感覺
另外一個就是你的思考邏輯
就是你的那個
Cognitive
function也會降低
所以你的思考也比較沒有彈性
你就會比較鑽牛角尖
你看我就是都已經這麼忙了
還怎麼樣怎麼樣
就沒有辦法跳開看到說
等一下
人家可能不是這樣子想
所以我覺得有一點
自創這個焦慮的劇本
那我自己是因為學了這一套
我才覺得
哦天啊
我一直覺得我
身邊人都是無能的
人或者是壞人
其實我才是那個
比較欠揍的那個人
你知道嗎就是
我共創了這個氛圍
可是我一直在
覺得是別人的問題
所以所以你在講這個東西
聽起來好吸引人
就是你這一堂課
不但可以幫助我們去看到
我們是怎麼樣
在這個環境裡面
共創出一個劇本
而且我每次都扮演什麼角色
另外我會有一些系統化的工具
可以幫助我去檢視
就是有東西可以讓我知道
我怎麼每次都扮演這個角色
我是不是可以調整一下
這個部分是這樣子嗎
對超讚的
我希望你看到了以後
你瞭解就是
你鬆動了你可能以前有的假設
譬如說我之前的假設
可能我老公問為什麼
就是他在挑戰我
這個假設正確嗎
我是不是可以用一些測試來
或者是想辦法多理解
說真的這個是假設是OK的嗎
還是是我自己亂想的
因為我們自己的假設
是來自於過去的經驗
對
那這過去的經驗不代表
我可以再把它
transfer到
現在這個人身上
所以我覺得有時候看到了以後
你就覺得好像
原來不是我想像的那樣子
我覺得
當我們沒有看懂整個局
你真的覺得你的
選擇是被侷限的
就是要嘛我就繼續
跟這個人在一起
可是我每天氣得要死
要嘛我就離婚
要嘛我就是留在這公司
要嘛我就是換一個公司
沒有其他的選擇
可是你好像鬆動看懂局以後
你可能發現
換個公司換個人
也許結果不會差太多
因為主角跟寫劇本的人是我
那我改了呢
我的人生
我的系統是不是就
可能有調整的空間
我剛剛想要講的就是說
我覺得我的課跟你的課
好適合康拜在一起
因為
我發現
因為我是個批人
所以我會在很多
雖然我已經很努力
想系統化很多東西
幫助大家去理解自己
但是環境的一些東西
那種要很系統
就是很清楚的那種有
條列式的工具這件事情
對我還是非常困難的
就是我就會覺得
那你就是知道你自己之後
看到什麼狀況
你就去因應
就是因為這是我最常做的事情
可是對於可能
跟我不一樣的朋友
對他來講
就是我可是我不知道怎麼因應
但我剛剛聽到你說
有一個系統化的工具
可以幫助大家
你有東西可以檢視
在你慌張的時候
在你不清楚的時候
我覺得這個東西真的非常棒
因為我剛剛想到就是
剛剛因為我最近
也有觀察到這件事情
就是有很多J人
像雪力老師說
就是很多J人
其實蠻負責任的
在進入一個事情
或是不一定是J人
但是他本身是一個在一個
遇到問題或遇到危機
或是遇到事情
他常常會覺得
他是那個要去解決問題的人
或是他是應該是要去幫別人
他看到什麼事情可以怎麼做
就剛剛雪力說的
就長女的習慣
可是很好玩的地方是
通常負這麼多責任
做這麼多事情
能力這麼好的人最常生氣
常常生氣
然後這個時候如果旁邊
有人還冷冷的說一句話說
可是我沒有拜託你做
我更生氣
就很生氣
我後來發現在遇到一個問題
我常常會跳下去
打不是自己的仗
例如說看到這個狀況
這件事情應該要怎麼做才對
我可能就會下去說
然後就變成了對方跟我做法
不同的那個人
變成是我們兩個在對戰
可是嚴格來說
我不一定不太能接受他的做法
只是我有感受到
可能另外一方他
因為他的這個做法
因為可能一邊是很P人
一邊是很J人
然後因為我跟J人常常相處
所以我很懂J人在想什麼
所以我會下去
可能就覺得你這樣做不行
應該要怎麼做才是
比較正確的做法
然後我會發現我在裡面
就常常擔任那一個
就是我可能要去
說正確的事情是什麼
然後怎麼做才是對的
或者是我要去
幫助誰的那個部分
可是其實有的時候
你並不一定要去做這件事情
甚至你進去做這件事情之後
該出現問題
該去討論的人
他們就沒辦法溝通
然後我覺得這個東西
非常的有趣
因為這也會讓我
比較容易生氣啊
那我們情緒比較多
可是實際上是因為
我去負了別人的責任
才造成這個問題
所以因為在我們的心理學裡面
有時候會講說
這是一個戲劇三角
就是所謂有的所謂的受害者
拯救者
還有就是攻擊者
可是不見得我們
三個是故意要去擔任
這個角色
而是很自然的動力
被這個角色卸
或是在這個局勢上就立刻
我們很習慣
就是我就是要進去解決問題的
我就很容易去擔任拯救者
就看到這個東西當然也很重要
但我很好奇
所以雪力像妳的在
講的系統課裡面
也有講到這一類的事情嗎
對
我如果跳進去
今天我要扮演是受害者的角色
那我肯定在每一個地方
我要找一個加害者
我一定要找一個人來攻擊
我要不然我這個劇本演不下去
這是有意識的嗎
我不覺得是有意識的
所以我希望大家可以透過系統
就是我有些掃描的工具
讓你看到你的
潛在的假設是什麼
你潛在的假設
我們就講冰山的地層是
我是一個受害者
因為我過去人生累積的經驗
我的劇本還是這樣的話
我一定要找一個攻擊我的人
就是那種感覺是
我以前被壓迫的經驗太多
所以不是我故意去當受害者
而是因為我有
太多被壓迫的經驗
所以我假設我很容易會被壓迫
或者是我會覺得
你只是譬如說你想要幫我
或者是你糾正我什麼事情
我可以把它詮釋成你在罵我
對吧
我就詮釋成周慕姿
之現在在攻擊我
我把這個劇本拿住了
我找到這個角色了以後
我一定可以找到一個
同樣有一些曾經想要拯救人
譬如說長女的
人跳出來說
周慕姿怎麼可以這樣對你
我去跟周慕姿講 對不對
一個保護的人就會出來了
那我就共創了這個劇本
可是一旦當我認知說
等一下我不是受害者
中睦子沒有要迫害我的時候
我們兩個互動就變了
這個人就沒有角色可以
他沒有人要保護了
他就只要在旁邊旁觀就好
他就只需要旁觀
因為他可能
如果他也抓著保護者的劇本
他會找別人
我們三個人的劫就打開了
所以有的時候你在系統裡面
你就是會卡住
那我想要分享一個
有一點是題外話
就是但是我覺得這個
這個研究非常有趣
我們很多時候會專注在
我們自己的感受
就是我自己感受到的
我聽到周慕姿這樣跟我講話的
所以我覺得他在對我兇
可是我要跟大家分享的就是
有的時候
你的感受跟你感官獲取的訊息
是會被外在影響的
我不知道你
有沒有聽過一個研究
叫做Auto-
Cognitive
Effect
它就是說我們在黑暗裡面
如果你看到一個點
那其實你盯著那個點很久
就是全黑的狀態下
那個點就會移動 對吧
那那個點移動
就有兩個實驗師
他們就再來做實驗說
我們把一群人放在一起
然後我們放幾個樁腳在裡面
那妝角就會講很誇張的數字
譬如說研究者就說
你們看到這個光移動多少
那樁腳就說
移動15英尺
15英尺其實很誇張
就不太可能
他就把妝角放進去講的時候
他就發現其他人
要不是不講話
要不然就說對差不多15英尺
然後慢慢你就發現說
當你這個妝角一個一個
拿開的時候
大家還是會講
然後新的人進去
再問大家還是說15英尺
可是慢慢這個文化就會消失
隨著你替換的人越來越多
就會有人說
哪有15英尺怎麼會這麼長
我要講的就是說
常常我們會專注在說
我聽到了
我知道的
因為我看到
我親眼看到
我親耳聽到的
可是我在分析這個實驗
我只是要告訴大家說
當你在一個文化裡面
你已經被這個文化
包圍跟侵蝕的時候
有的時候你的詮釋
不一定是所謂的事實
是不是可以透過一個系統來
檢視
這真的是事實嗎
我可不可以用一些
行動研究來測試
我的假設
我的想法真的是對的嗎
也許是對的
對不對
我們剛在講長女的時候
也許父母真的是就
要求你做所有的事情
但是也許他們對
你的要求沒有那麼高
那你可以去測試看看
如果沒測試就覺得
啊 大家都期待我做這件事情
那你也真的太冤了
所以你剛講
我真的有看到很多長女
或者是很多很有能力的人
其實他們都是滿肚子火的
就是真的又是家裡
付最多責任的人
可是卻是家裡最不討喜的人
人家出去吃飯也不想約他
因為一約他出來他又開始罵人
可是他又是承擔
最多家裡責任的人
就是我覺得
以前我也隱隱約約拿著那個劇本
那就覺得何必這樣子呢
就是其實你放手
可以大家一起都很開心的
所以我聽雪力在講這個東西
我覺得這一個系統課
他有幾個很重要的概念
因為他不但幫助我們去看懂
就是除了因為原本我可能
越來越理解自己
可是我不知道我在
這一個環境裡面
怎麼被影響
所以我看得懂環境
我也瞭解在這個環境中
我怎麼被影響
然後我想辦法在這個環境裡面
怎麼樣去長出我自己的東西
所以那個東西包含界線
包含我怎麼用比較後來的眼光
就是第三者的眼光去看
這個系統怎麼
讓我在裡面滾來滾去
讓我可以有新的選擇
所以我有工具
這個工具可以幫
我去做這樣的事情
然後我去做這樣的事情之後
我更清楚
我就敢去測試
因為我有工具
我自己就像我常常說界線
那你就試試看
因為現在我就是批人
我就覺得你就是試試看
反正也不會發生什麼事
然後我在猜可能有
很多J人都覺得
老師你好不可靠
就是怎麼可以隨便測測看
可是如果你是J人的話
說不定在
因為畢竟雪力老師就是J人
所以這個是好適合J人的東西
就是你有一個他很清楚的工具
然後這個東西
就可以幫助你去測試
就是我在這裡面
我大概就知道嘛
有方向有計畫
我要做哪些東西
哪些東西要確認
有Checklist
這個好棒哦
你的一些
正在影響你人生的假設
就是我必須這麼做
我如果
我只有這條路
就是我們
在壓力下
你看不清楚你有很多條路
你好像只有
我要嘛接受
要嘛就不做了
其實你有很多不同的選擇
就像你說的試試看
剛剛講啊
晚一點交會怎麼樣
好像也不會怎麼樣
也不會怎麼樣
你一旦理解
你可以共創一些新的局面
就是你可能沒有
辦法想像的局面
我要不是當初學這個東西
我不可能45歲
才開始做
YouTube這件事情
因為
你的內在的假設是
那個是年輕人做的
哦
就是我那時候開始學
就覺得所有的挑戰
所有的假設
我是不是都要去試試看
或者是
中年婦女
再來出來做的內容可能
不太會吸引人
這些假設事實上看起來很像真的
但是我很幸運的就是
我有去測試
但如果當時
我這樣子跟別人分享
別人
很多人會說對對對啊
是真的有點晚了
那這條路就沒了耶
原來如此
因為我剛剛想
我都會在想說
什麼
就是這些邏輯
我全部都沒想過
但我覺得
也許這就是為什麼
你有時候會很喜歡
跟我聊天的原因
因為我都沒想過這些事情
因為你會挑戰我的一些假設
我覺得非常的棒
但是很多時候
我們自己都沒有想到說
這個是假設
你覺得在你的人生中
這已經是真理了
因為太習慣了
這個就是你人生的濾鏡
所以當你有這種好朋友
或者是沒有好朋友
就是要靠系統
我來檢視一下
等一下
有些工具
對
我可能不一定是真實是這樣子
我覺得這個東西非常有趣是
一方面是我覺得可能以後
你的企劃跟行銷
他們聽到這一段之後
就會想以後
你要做課或寫書之前
會就是嚴禁跟募資人
的聯絡人聯絡
然後另外一個部分是我覺得
剛剛在講的課
有一個非常重要的關鍵
就也許大家會覺得說
那好像還是我去挑戰假設
那這個東西跟系統的關係
可是這很有關係
因為我們有很多假設
跟我們去抓取
這個系統的暗示
跟這個系統的期待
其實有很大的關係
如果我們不瞭解
這個系統的文化
我們不瞭解這個系統
是怎麼暗示我們
跟怎麼期待我們
我們的性格又在什麼部分
會讓我們去接受這些東西
我可能不會發現
為什麼我總是在這一個系統
都在扮演某一個角色
所以這一個部分
除了自我的認知之外
去瞭解系統對我們的影響
也很重要
但最重要其實是工具
就是剛剛學弟講這個
我覺得超讚
就是我有工具知道
我知道了
然後呢
我有怎麼樣的選擇
我可以怎麼做
那如果你不是批人
或是你想要有一個更清楚的
檢視標準
我覺得這個東西
就是一個很快的
可以幫助我們開始
可以跳出這個角色的
一個非常棒的工具
真的
我覺得
當然課程裡面有
很多就是掃描你的
潛意識
掃描你的團隊
現在有可能面臨
到什麼樣的狀態
好帥
就是團隊包含你的關係
或者現在組織裡面
因為你但看到了
也許你沒有辦法扭轉這個環境
可是你就不會這麼痛苦
對不對
那我剛講到假設
我想要提一個案例
就是這是實際的個案
就是當你的假設
跟公司文化的
假設有衝突的時候
你會覺得我到底做錯了什麼
對不對
有一個個案我在
課程裡面有分享
就是他有一點社恐
所以他做事情都要戴口罩
可是他的環境有一點
是比較外向的環境
就是有一點製作節目這樣子
所以他一直戴著口罩
然後事情也都做好
做都做完了
時間都沒有遲到
可是他的主管就覺得他不社交
他不是一個team
player
團隊的假設是大家要嘻嘻哈哈
就是這樣子才是
一個團隊的好成員
因為他們團隊的氛圍是這樣子
你一個人戴著口罩在旁邊工作
很明顯的就是你
不願意加入我們
你不夠努力
但是對他來說
我該做的都做了
也許做更多
那他的假設是這樣子就夠了
我覺得是工作
工作的假設不是這樣
工作文化的假設
是不一樣的時候
你就會覺得為什麼
在公司被人排擠
我明明把我該做的都做了
所以這個感覺就
很像是這一個文化
是希望你把你自己放進去
你不是只有工作的那個模式
但是他的習慣就是
我來工作就是來工作
所以你看我們的工作細節是
登在網路上面
我們現在招募人
就是業務要做什麼什麼
工作時數薪資什麼什麼
可是那個潛在的
文化沒有人列出來
沒錯
所以你要到了環境才知道
潛在的文化有這麼多假設
可是你不知道的時候
你就覺得
你們登的這些東西
我每個都做到啦
到底是為什麼老闆
一直在挑我毛病
你知道了你就有選擇
我要改我不要改
要不然你就覺得你
就是受害者而已
或找一個新的環境
我最後想問雪力一個
因為大家可能
已經對於這個課程
本身就是他在說什麼
或是我可以獲得什麼
有比較清楚的部分
但是呢
其實還有很多很棒的部分
包含我們剛剛講到掃描潛意識
掃描你的就是系統的潛意識
這真的很酷
這個太酷了
所以大家自己去看課
我們這麼酷的東西
不能隨便就讓你知道
但是呢
我們還有一個很重要的東西
我覺得很有趣
因為你有講到
你這次也還是有講
一點點 MBTI
講的是
MBTI 的防衛基準
所以這個部分雪力可以簡單的
我們不能講太多
我們只能講一點點
然後雪力可以幫
我們分享一下下嗎
我覺得你剛剛講的
譬如說T人尤其是TP的人
在碰到問題或者是挑戰的時候
他會更抓住他舒服
或者他認為是對的東西
對的東西就是事實到底是什麼
對
所以你們不要講這些虛偽的話
好像不是講雞湯話的時候
現在我們要追求的
這個事實是什麼
就是越是在壓力下
越開始專注在這一點
所以就會形成角色鎖定
就變成我越來越覺得說
這個募資怎麼這麼不敬人情
不敬人情沒有同理
可是這是因為我們雙方都在
壓力下的時候
我們就比較容易鎖住
那譬如說FJ 的人
其實我們不要講F的人
F的人其實當他在
壓力下最會情勒人
FJ 的人他的核心價值
是我希望團隊是和諧的
所以平常就是
可能是很棒的康樂鼓掌
是一個團隊的
這個黏著劑對不對
但是他在壓力下的時候
他也會說
周牧芝你講話小心一點
不然其他人會生氣
大家都要不要這樣子
不要那樣子
他會開始設邊界
對大家情緒不要表現出來
我們要維持這個和諧
未來要維持這個和諧
所以我要講的就是
我們FJ 的人
其實在安全的狀況下
他是小太陽
在非常焦慮緊張狀況下
他是有可能會去勤勒別人的
TP 的人在安全的狀況下
他是非常好的QA
對會問別人想不到的問題
在這個焦慮的狀況下
是抓著問題不放的人
而且會讓大家壓力很大
對就是
這個問題不解決
我們大家哪裡都不要覺得
對對對
差不多是這樣
就是為什麼要討論別的事情
現在這個問題要先解決
對所以我覺得我要
透過 MBTI
再帶大家進去的就是說
你不要看說你是什麼類型
你就一定怎麼樣
因為你在不同的系統裡面
你會有不同的反應
那我只是希望帶大家用
譬如說類型來看說
你看你在安全的狀況下
跟不安全的狀況下
你的反應就會不一樣
你的那個機制你的假設
就會引導你有不同的行為
所以我們不要再卡在
MBTI 上面了
就是我之前去做工作坊
都會有人問說
老師 我兒子說他是I人
可是他每天都出去
我就心想說
他是不是不想要留在家裡
對不對
他就不想
或者是我的老公說他是E人
可是他都不跟我講話
是不是有可能是
別的原因對不對
就是我們不要再卡在
MBTI 本身
就是要看到說
人是會因為互動而改變
沒錯
我覺得這個東西
可以幫我們更拓展
我們的一些看見跟想法
然後其實我真的覺得
雖然雪力老師常說
你在我身上就是得到很多東西
但是我真的從你身上
得到非常多東西
就是包含就是在很多
就是之前在
MBTI 課的時候
我也對我自己有多一點理解
跟後來像這一次系統課
我也非常非常期待
因為我覺得這個系統
真的真的
我覺得這個系統動力
它其實是在我們文化中
非常非常重要的一個部分
然後為什麼
這個人會在這個
時間點做這樣的事情
然後為什麼一定會有一個
代罪羔羊出現
然後最後甚至
我不能說都是這樣
但是我覺得有的時候
當整個就是常常會講說
霸凌會發生在一個環境
它的競爭越激烈的時候
那個霸凌的狀況其實會越產生
而這個是不是跟
焦慮的傳遞也有關係
它必須要有一個帶最高揚
大家的焦慮跟壓力
要有地方可以放
可是我說的並不是霸凌
這件事情是可以發生的
我說的是
它如果當我們今天用一個系統
跟團體動力去看的時候
這件事情可能就不是只
focus在個人
而是它可能跟一個團體的焦慮
跟團體的一個現象
系統的狀況有關
所以對這個東西有興趣的朋友
我相信有很多人在學心理學
或是對於心理學
相關的東西有興趣
我猜很多人就是花很多時間
注重在個人
然後大家對別人
已經沒有什麼興趣了
就是我會只想看個人
可是我覺得在看個人這件事情
一定會遇到一個卡關
我也很誠實的說
當我遇到很多人在問我說
老師我知道我個人
我也知道怎麼處理
可是我的環境有很多變化
那我遇到這個環境變化
我要怎麼辦的時候
我心裡想說就因應啊
因為我好無情
不是
因為TP很會因應
OK
就是你知道你這跟
J人講說
蛤
那
還好對不對
但是因為P傾向的人
他這邊本來天生是靈活的
所以這真的是我的錯
而我發現這雪力…
老師的這一個課
可以讓就是也許你在生命中
你已經開始覺得
你比較瞭解自己
你也瞭解你的一些狀態
跟你很容易出現的模式
可是你在面對就是環境的變化
跟環境的狀況說
你還是很容易卡住
而你不知道怎麼辦的時候
這邊有系統的工具可以教你
而且雪力老師本來就是組織
心理學的就是強棒啊
所以大家如果想要對這個部分
你個人有興趣的話
也非常非常歡迎大家
可以參考水利老師的課
所以剛剛啊
我們在中間的內容
我相信大家可能
還是會很有興趣
就是如果我在組織裡面
很容易變成一個受害者
很容易變成一個代罪羔羊
甚至我在家裡
我就很容易會成為這樣的角色
或是我也很容易會有長女病啊
我在家裡永遠
都是那個做苦勞工
還不會太惱那樣子的人
我在上這個課
我會有什麼樣的方法
或有怎麼樣的狀況
可以幫助我
讓我可以一步一步的去看到
然後甚至調整這樣的事情
我覺得有幾件事情
第一個就是
嗯
你要先看到就是
到底現在是什麼劇本
一直不停的在重演
對不對
所以你先掃描到說
欸我好像每一次
就是人家打來
我就生氣說
你又沒做完
好啦好啦我幫你
然後結果就是我一肚子氣
然後他也不謝謝我
好每一次都是
這樣子的事情重演
那下一次
我可不可以找一個小小的
變動因素來調整
就他在打給我的時候
我試試看嘛
所以我第一步我先來規劃
我要選哪一個點
我選的點是
我接電話的口氣就不一樣
所以我這次接電話的時候
我可能先規劃
然後我就第二步就是行動
我就會說
慕姿最近超忙的
哦我真的累到生病了
然後
我來觀察
你有什麼樣子的反應
然後結果ㄧ不一樣
那結果有可能就不一樣
就說哦那沒事了算了算了
我本來想請你幫忙的
可能請你一下
但你看看起來也很忙
那我就不麻煩你了
那我這個
我這個行動研究就成功了
我找到一個可以解套的方式
但是也有可能就是
哎這個不成功
啊你生病了
可是我真的很需要你幫忙啊
等等等等好這次不成功
我下次再改一個東西
我不接電話了
我要找到一個方式
就是我用行動來微調
就是我不是讓你覺得
我這個人就變了
我也不可能這麼快就變
因為我們的劇本都拿了這麼久
會被吸引回去
你每次調整一下
然後看哎這個有用哦
有用我在繼續調
沒有用沒關係
我們就換一個方式
那剛講的是如果我總是被變成
代罪羔羊或者是我
被投射說要做
這個守護者的角色
那我講一下
我之前跟我的老大好了
就是剛開始要
進入青春期的時候
開始講話就要理不理的就嗯哼
要不然就是不回
然後我就會越來越大聲
然後這個劇本就變成
你回話啊，你怎麼不講啊
越講越大聲
他說你這麼兇幹嘛
每次就是這樣子的互動
那我我後來就想說
哎我試試看
我又在講說哎哎哎
怎麼樣怎麼樣
沒聲音
我第一個調整就是
好那你現在可能在忙
我之後再回來找你
或者是等你有空
你來找我有件事想跟你談
這次很幸運
試一次就成功了
是隔了兩三個小時
到晚上刷完牙以後才說
媽你剛剛找我幹嘛
好那我就發現說
哦這個劇本已經被我改寫了
那我就在我們兩個
關係比較好的時候
安全的時候
我試圖再重寫這個劇本
說哎有的時候我講話
你不理我
那你希望我怎麼樣做
你覺得會比較好一點
所以因為我是比較有權力的那一方
所以有的時候
老闆掌權的父母
要改寫劇本更加的容易
因為他只能反抗
或者說好
那如果要建立一個健康的關係
我一定要負更多的責任
所以我覺得在跟我老大的身上
因為我開始學的時候
剛剛好是我老大
在轉大人的時候
所以那時候我們的關係
相對的是緊張的
所以我學這個這一套
我覺得實際就是實驗在
我們兩個的身上
我就馬上的看到
我們的關係好轉
那種張力其實已經
大概好幾個月也許一年
可是真的就是
幾個禮拜很明顯的
我們的互動就不一樣
所以雪力老師你的這一套
剛剛說那個
我們大家可以
有一些微型的調整
行動這個方法在
你的課叫做什麼
這個叫做Action
Research
行動研究
這就是行動研究的四個步驟
其實現在很多實驗學校
教的也是行動研究
其實就是這四個步驟
就是我先規劃
然後我行動
我觀察
然後我再檢討反思
那反思的過程在這裡面
又會教大家另外
一個就是 AAR
就是我期待發生什麼事情
實際發生什麼事情
跟我想的有什麼不一樣
我從這裡有什麼學習
所以你知道
J人就最喜歡
全部都塞系統
所有都是一大堆SOP
SOP
我剛剛其實覺得很有趣
因為這個課
雪力老師
會很清楚地講這個東西
因為我
我剛剛在聽雪力
你在講這個東西
跟我在內耗課
教大家改變的那個步驟很像
可是我不知道
行動研究這個東西
我是自己想出來的
所以你更厲害
沒有
可是我覺得你講
這樣子就好清楚
因為大家就知道
我也覺得蠻開心的
這樣子大家就知道
我不是在亂講
真的有一個研究在講這個東西
其實是一樣的
因為我們能夠這樣子調整
而我又可以去思考
我到底期待是什麼
那我想要改變什麼
然後我再做調整
我覺得這真的非常棒
所以大家如果對於
不管是系統也好
或家庭也好
有一些覺得困難
然後我開始想要
有一些方法調整
其實雪力老師
會帶著我們做這些事情對不對
是是是
真的是太讚了各位朋友
好的
大家一定很期待
雪力老師的
「人生系統設計課」
這個部分
相關的資訊還有優惠
到底是怎麼樣呢
當然啊
雪力老師是我的好朋友
所以我一定有優惠嘛
當然
然後因為
就是我也算是
蠻前面
就是雪力老師
來上我的節目
是是是
所以大家看到這個課的時候呢
價格還是非常優惠
因此
請大家如果有興趣的朋友
直接看我們的資訊欄
裡面有我們的優惠碼
還有呢
我們的課程資訊
某方面來說
這很誠實的講
我也不是什麼業配都會接
但雪力老師的課
我真的～非常非常推薦
而且剛剛跟雪力老師
聊的過程中
我非常相信這一堂課
可以幫助我們很多
而且可以補充很多
我們現在對於心理學
或是對自我的一些
認識
以外的一些部分
讓我們更瞭解系統
還有關係
跟別人的互動
對我們的影響
不但可以用在你的關係裡
用在你的家庭裡
還可以用在
你的企業跟你的工作裡
這是一件非常棒的事情
所以
歡迎大家有興趣
可以參考
雪力老師的新課
謝謝
謝謝 謝謝大家
謝謝慕姿
不會
謝謝雪力老師開這門課
那
真的
今天很感謝雪力老師
前來
然後
希望大家喜歡
我們今天的分享
那麼
周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
拜拜